i
[Música]
se evidencian las fracturas dentro del
partido republicano de eeuu después de
que el ex presidente de donald trump
emitiera un comunicado atacando
directamente al líder de la bancada en
el senado mitch mcconnell como ofreció
apoyo a quienes compitan con
relacionador en las próximas primarias
tenemos reportes de washington
al menos 22 personas han vuelto en el
norte de méxico y el sur de eeuu a causa
de la ola de frío que golpea la región
con temperaturas de hasta 15 grados bajo
cero el fenómeno ha dejado también a
millones de personas en ambos países sin
servicio eléctrico miles de vuelos han
sido cancelados durante los últimos días
y hoy se registra un protejo de la
región española de cataluña donde miles
de personas se manifestaron contra la
detención del rapero pablo hasél el
artista señalado de enaltecimiento del
terrorismo e injurias contra la corona y
las instituciones estatales por el
contenido de sus canciones
volvemos con más información de américa
latina y del mundo aquí en las 24 yo soy
liliana valencia iniciamos en eeuu
porque hoy se concretó la fractura
dentro del partido republicano tras el
segundo impeachment contra donald trump
este martes a través de un comunicado el
ex presidente atacó directamente al día
de la minoría republicana en el senado
mitch mcconnell tran visto a los
seguidores a los integrantes del partido
a rechazar su liderazgo en la bancada en
la cámara alta ampliamos esta
información con nuestro corresponsal en
washington en cristóbal vázquez
cristóbal buenas noches y cuéntenos cómo
se recibe en washington el comunicado de
donald trump atacando al líder
republicano del senado evidencia de esto
las fracturas y qué significa para el
futuro del partido
se veía llegar a esta división entre
trump y mitch mcconnell porque
michoacano durante cuatro años fue el
que respaldó todo tipo de iniciativas de
trump en el senado pero el sábado pasado
tras la votación y tras haber votado
para absolver a don autor del
impeachment michoacán lo pronunció un
discurso donde responsabilizaba práctica
y moralmente a donald trump de los
ataques del pasado 6 de enero al
capitolio esta posición el respaldo
mitch mcconnell también en un euro pero
en una columna de opinión en el 'wall
street' turno algo que no le gustó para
nada a donald trump quien pues publica
este comunicado quien además dice que si
el partido republicano sigue en cabeza
de líderes como mick macro nos va a
perder su respeto además según el asesor
jason miller el comunicado va a ser aún
mucho más fuerte criticando lo aburrido
y lo tosco que era mitch mcconnell pero
que jason miller precisamente filtró el
comunicado y no lo dejó por ejemplo
adoro publicar ataques personales como
que en michoacán no tenía triple papada
su cara que tenía un aspecto físico
agradable pero pues eso obviamente no
cae nada bien en el partido republicano
y obviamente pues divide aún más las
dobles las dos vertientes que quedan en
la cámara alta por un lado mitch
mcconnell y otros republicanos como
pensadas para tommy y en lisa murkowski
y por otro lado pues el ala que apoya al
expresidente donald trump y está a la la
apoya
lindsey graham de cruz y mike leake
senadores republicanos que a pesar de lo
que pasó la semana pasada siguen
apoyando a donald trump así que se
divide aún más el partido republicano
esto paralelamente a pues el anuncio de
nosotros de querer formar un tercer
partido político gracias a nuestro
corresponsal en washington cristóbal
vázquez y continuamos en la región
porque la ola de frío que golpea al sur
de eeuu y el norte de méxico deja al
menos 22 muertos además de millones de
personas sin servicio eléctrico en ambos
países el temporal también dificulta el
tránsito terrestre y miles de vuelos han
sido cancelados
tormenta traerá a temperaturas de hasta
15 grados bajo cero ampliamos esta
información con miguel ángel perales
director de protección civil del estado
de nuevo léon que se conecta con
nosotros desde monterrey bienvenida bajo
habrás veinticuatro y cuéntenos señor
perales por favor de escribanos un poco
con la situación que se vive en el norte
de méxico y qué cifra nos puede brindar
en cuanto a familias damnificadas y
daños materiales
noche 02 gracias por este espacio
nosotros aquí en el estado nuevo león
pues estamos muy cercanos al estado de
texas en la frontera con eeuu y está
pues tormenta invernal este frío ártico
también ha nuevo léon ha afectado
fuertemente las principales
problemáticas que se han dado en el
estado ha sido la formación de capas de
hielo en las vías de comunicación en
algunas de las principales avenidas de
la zona metropolitana de monterrey en
donde vive prácticamente el 92 por
ciento de la población del estado se
vieron afectadas y si fuera necesario
realizar algunos operativos de cierre y
alternativas viales para evitar
accidentes en estos lugares por el
riesgo que hay para los automovilistas
algunas carreteras como la vía laredo
precisamente la carretera autopista de
cuota a laredo texas se vio afectada en
el kilómetro 37 en la altura conocida
como la cuesta mamulique en donde la
formación de dos capas de hielo una en
un lado y otra en otras permitió que
quedaban varados
una caravana de vehículos en este lugar
temperaturas de menos 8 y menos graves y
28 grados bajo cero 10 grados bajo cero
con personas varadas ahí fue necesario
implementar un operativo de ayuda
humanitaria y de auxilio para ellos para
verificar las condiciones en las que se
encontraban proporcionarles algo de
abrigo alimentación y obviamente estar
con ellos hasta que se pudiera liberar
esta problemática que estuvo ahí y el
tema de la falla de la energía eléctrica
que los estados del noreste del país
seis estados del país es vieron
afectados nuevo león no fue la excepción
que ha estado paulatinamente
restableciendo t pero intermitentemente
funcionando no no por completo y que
bueno hemos estado vigilando que los
hospitales principalmente están operando
de manera normal las instalaciones
estratégicas y obviamente al pendiente
de la población que esté pues muy muy
comunicada con nosotros en caso de que
se requiera algo de esas 22 personas que
comentaba hace un momento que perdieron
la vida cuatro de ellos fueron aquí en
el estado de nuevo léon lamentablemente
personas que viven en situación de calle
e situación vulnerable en aparente signo
de hipotermia y una de ellas que murió
por síntomas de intoxicación por
monóxido de carbono al utilizar un
calentador de gas en malas condiciones
en las sillón de tu hogar
bueno pues agradecemos este reporte
desde el norte de méjico y continuamos
con más noticias porque la organización
de estados americanos oea manifestó su
preocupación ante la demora en el
reconteo de votos en ecuador para las
elecciones presidenciales del pasado 7
de febrero
nueve días después de los comicios aún
no se sabe quién se enfrentará en
segunda vuelta al candidato del
correísmo andrés araus los opcionados
son el banquero guillermo lasso y el
candidato indígena ya q pérez quien
exige un reconteo de los votos en 17
provincias del país el pleno del consejo
nacional electoral sesionará esta noche
para debatir la viabilidad de la
propuesta y se espera una respuesta
definitiva
el rapero español pablo hasél fue
detenido en la mañana de este martes por
la policía en la universidad de lleida
donde se había atrincherado el lunes
para evitar su arresto el artista deberá
cumplir nueve meses de prisión tras ser
condenado por enaltecimiento del
terrorismo e injurias contra la corona
por el contenido de sus letras y algunos
de sus trinos manifestantes salieron a
las calles de distintas ciudades de
cataluña y valencia para pedir su
libertad
la rabia se extendió por las calles de
catalunya incendios destrozos y choques
entre policía y manifestantes se
vivieron en barcelona y otras ciudades
de la región española en la capital
catalana una joven resultó gravemente
herida en un ojo el motivo de la
protesta la encarcelación del rapero
español pablo hasél
[Aplausos]
no nos van a doblegar con toda la
represión
estas eran las palabras dejase el más
pronto el martes al ser detenido por la
policía en la universidad de lleida allí
se habían cerrado el lunes para
dificultar su arresto tras exceder el
viernes la fecha límite para entrar
voluntariamente en prisión el artista
deberá enfrentar nueve meses de cárcel
tras ser condenado por delitos de
enaltecimiento del terrorismo' e
injurias contra la corona y las
instituciones del estado español en sus
canciones no voy a permitir que me
dicten lo que tengo que pensar lo que
tengo que sentir lo que tengo que decir
lo que tengo que hacer la sentencia ha
generado un amplio debate en torno a la
llamada ley mordaza aprobada en 2015 por
el gobierno conservador de mariano rajoy
que supuso un recorte en las libertades
de los ciudadanos
wolves thing y fue sofol en primer lugar
creo que es un derecho expresar tu
opinión ya sea rapeando ya sea cantando
ya sea bailando ya sea haciendo lo que
creas claro la semana pasada más de 200
artistas firmaron un manifiesto en apoyo
a hasél de hecho españa fue el país con
más artistas encarcelados en 2019 por
delante de turquía e irán
la organización en premios la asamblea
nacional de francia aprobó el proyecto
de ley contra el separatismo islamista
que desde el 30 de marzo seguirá su
trámite parlamentario en el senado el
texto fue presentado por el gobierno de
manuel macrón como una defensa de los
valores de la república y para combatir
el radicalismo islamista pero la medida
despertó controversia y recibió críticas
tanto de la derecha como de la izquierda
política y forma de federico cué
barberena es el proyecto emblema del
gobierno francés para combatir el
llamado radicalismo islámico la asamblea
nacional le dio el visto bueno en
primera lectura al proyecto de ley
contra el separatismo mientras el
oficialismo lo presenta como una defensa
de la república el texto ha sido
criticado tanto desde la derecha como
desde la izquierda esta ley garantiza
nuestra necesidad del laicismo luego de
grandes avances en acciones públicas
segundo protege a las víctimas del
separatismo
texto no podemos votar este proyecto que
no cumple con su misión y está lejos de
ser un gran texto
es cualquier cosa menos una ley de
restauración de principios republicanos
es una ley que se usó durante dos
semanas en realidad para señalar con el
dedo a nuestros compatriotas de religión
musulmana entre otras cosas el texto
imponer la neutralidad religiosa a
trabajadores de servicios públicos
supedita subvenciones públicas al
respeto de los valores republicanos
impone controles a las donaciones para
entidades religiosas y ongs y castiga el
odio en línea fue propuesto tras la
decapitación del profesor samuel para ti
en octubre luego de que mostrara una
caricatura de mahoma en clase pero para
los musulmanes alienta la discriminación
hablamos sobre radicales no sé qué es
eso un musulmán es un musulmán y eso es
todo
esto va a ser destructivo para todos los
franceses sean musulmanes cristianos o
judíos va a crear muchos problemas para
el islam
paul island tras su aprobación en la
asamblea nacional el proyecto continuará
su trámite parlamentario desde el 30 de
marzo en el senado
en noticias del continente africano la
organización mundial de la salud
confirmó el inicio de una campaña de
vacunación contra el virus del ébola en
la república democrática del congo
trabajadores de la salud en el centro
médico de matanza en la ciudad de
butembo donde fueron tratados los
primeros pacientes con la enfermedad
fueron los primeros inoculados el país
confirmó cuatro casos de ébola desde el
7 de febrero según la oms 1.200 dosis de
la vacuna fueron entregadas
recientemente nuestra nación del
continente guinea declaró una epidemia
de ébola tras registrar tres muertes
organizaciones de derechos humanos piden
a israel que deje pasar dos mil dosis de
la vacuna rusa a gasa en territorio
palestino un bloqueo que consideran que
viola la convención de ginebra de
derechos humanos por su parte israel que
ya ha vacunado a más de cuatro millones
de ciudadanos con una primera dosis se
exige recuperar a dos civiles y los
cuerpos de dos soldados retenidos en
casa mientras que ofrece a los israelíes
pizza gratis a cambio de vacunarse
informa luís muñoz
el bloqueo a gaza se ve reflejado
incluso en las vacunas contra el kobe 19
este martes las 2.000 dosis de la
solución rusa sputnik be tampoco
llegaron a la franja autoridades
palestinas denuncian desde el lunes que
israel está bloqueando la llegada de
vacunas
el bloqueo es un crimen real y una
violación de todas las leyes
internacionales así como los derechos
humanos al off él enseña por el momento
palestina sólo ha recibido 12.000 dosis
que han sido aplicadas al personal de
salud de cisjordania 10.000 han sido una
donación de rusia mientras que 2000
llegaron de israel sin embargo israel
para dejar entrar las vacunas en gaza
exige la devolución de dos civiles y de
los cuerpos de dos soldados que murieron
en la guerra de 2014 y que están
retenidos en gaza la organización
israelí y que trata de proteger el libre
movimiento de los palestinos denunció la
situación israel no sólo bloqueó el paso
de dos mil vacunas a gaza sino que
también continúa desconociendo su
obligación legal
al garantizar que la vacuna esté
disponible en las ocupadas cisjordania y
gaza mientras que gaza sufre un bloqueo
por tierra mar y aire desde 2007 israel
ya ha vacunado a 4 millones de personas
con la primera dosis en la operación de
inoculación más rápida del mundo y ante
la disponibilidad de vacunas en tel aviv
incluso están tratando de atraer a los
israelíes para que se vacunen contra el
cubil 19 con pizza gratis finalizamos en
grecia la acrópolis de atenas amaneció
este martes bajo un manto de nieve al
igual que otros antiguos monumentos
ofreciendo un espectáculo excepcional en
medio de la ola de frío que afecta al
país la nevada obligó a posponer la
campaña de vacunación contra el cob y 19
en la capital griega también se
registraron cortes eléctricos y
problemas en el sistema de transporte
así finalizamos de prada 24 ustedes
continúan con más entradas 24 punto com
[Música]